how's it going everybody so this morning
we were treated to some Avengers four
leaked concept art the concept art is of
Thor and Rocket Raccoon and it could
tell us just a little bit more
information about Avengers 4 if you're
new to my channel I'm currently doing a
giveaway giving away a few copies of
Avengers infinity war or ant-man and the
wasp on blu-ray some special edition
posters and memorabilia all the
aptitudes enter is subscribe to my
channel like this video and comment
below with your thoughts and your
favorite superhero so as you can see
here we have Thor rocket and if you look
at the bottom right of the picture we
see Captain America is actually wearing
the suit as well I will get into why I
think Captain Marvel doesn't actually
need this suit in just a little bit so
some people were saying that these are
spacesuits well that doesn't really make
any sense seen as how Thor spent the
first half of infinity war floating
around in space the first half when his
ship was destroyed and the guardians of
the galaxy picked him up and then again
when he was on net of layer trying to
awaken the heart of the dying star so
space suits don't really make that much
sense because Thor doesn't need one and
if it doesn't need one I don't think
he's wearing this suit some people are
saying that it's the Future foundation
Fantastic Four but seeing as how the
Disney Foxx deal isn't officially done
yet I do not think that's what this is
what I do think the suits are for is for
traveling inside of the quantum realm to
me this makes the most sense because the
quantum realm is said to have a huge
part in Avengers 4 and not to mention
it's heavily rumoured that it will play
a big part in Captain Marvel as well
there's actually been some speculation
and rumors that Captain Marvel could
possibly get her powers from the quantum
realm in the movie or she could possibly
get trapped inside of the quantum realm
at the end of the movie which would
explain why she doesn't need a suit not
to mention these suits kind of look like
the suit that Hank Pym war in ant-man
and the wasp when he went inside the
quantum realm himself they look pretty
similar but they're not a hundred
percent identical and this is probably
because Hank Pym has turned to dust so
if these suits are for traveling inside
of the quantum realm they're most likely
made by Tony Stark and Bruce Banner with
the help of Scott Lang and Carol Danvers
to me this just makes the
most sense we know that there's time
travel and Avengers for it we know that
there are time vortexes inside of the
quantum realm we learned that from the
post-credits scene in ant-man and the
wasp and we know you need suits to go
inside of the quantum realm and again
these suits look kind of similar to the
one that Hank Pym wore and ant-man and
the wasp so I'm going to go ahead and
say that these suits are for traveling
inside of the quantum realm but let me
know what you all think hit me with your
thoughts in the comments below let me
know what you think of the suits and let
me know if you think they're for
travelling inside of the quantum realm
or something else don't forget to
subscribe like and comment below with
your thoughts and your favorite
superhero to enter the giveaway and so
you can say up-to-date with everything
related to Avengers 4 as always thank
you so much for watching
woof woof
[Music]